MURDER OF THE JOURNALIST, JAMAL
KHASOGGI.
>> Bret: PETER, THANK YOU.
JOINING ME NOW IS THE COSPONSORS
OF THAT SENATE BILL,
BERNIE SANDERS.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Bret: WHY IS THIS
IMPORTANT?
>> IT IS VITAL THAT EVERYONE IN
AMERICA UNDERSTANDS WHAT IS
GOING ON IN YEMEN NOW.
IT IS THE WORST HUMANITARIAN
CRISIS FACING THIS PLANETS.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IN THE LAST
THREE YEARS AS A RESULT OF THE
SAUDI LED INTERVENTION IN THE
YEMEN CIVIL WAR.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 85,000
CHILDREN ALREADY STARVED TO
DEATH.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT IMMINENT
STARVATION FOR MILLIONS MORE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT 10,000
CASES OF CHOLERA MAKING OUT
EVERY SINGLE WEEK.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A GENERATION
OF YEMEN'S CHILDREN WHO WILL BE
STUNTED, PHYSICALLY AND
INTELLECTUALLY BECAUSE OF THE
FAMINE THAT IS NOW IN EXISTENCE.
WE HAVE TO AND THAT'S.
FURTHERMORE, I THINK WE HAVE TO
SAY, THE SAUDI GOVERNMENT WHICH
IS A DESPOTIC GOVERNMENT, WHICH
ALLOWS NO CONSENTS, WHICH TREATS
WOMEN AS THIRD CLASS CITIZENS.
WE WILL NOT FOLLOW THEIR
MILITARY ADVENTURISM INTO YEMEN.
THE LAST POINT AS TO WHY IT IS
IMPORTANT AND PEOPLE LIKE
SENATOR MIKE LEE, CONSERVATIVES
ARE MAKING THIS AND
PROGRESSIVES.
FOR DECADES ON THE REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT AND DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS, REPUBLICAN CONGRESS
AND DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS IS, THE
CONGRESS OF THE UNITED STATES
HAS ADVOCATED ITS CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY OVER WARMAKING.
IT IS NOT THE PRESIDENT WHO HAS
EARS POSSIBILITY UNDER THE
CONSTITUTION TO SEND OUR TROOPS.
IT IS CONGRESS.
WE HAVE TO TAKE IT BACK.
>> Bret: MITCH McCONNELL
MENTIONED THAT WITH THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OVER WAR
POWERS, THIS MAY SPARK FROM HIS
POINT OF VIEW.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP LAST NIGHT ON
THE ISSUE OF YEMEN.
HE SAID, I AM MUCH MORE OPEN TO
YEMEN BECAUSE FRANKLY I HATE TO
SEE WHAT IS GOING ON IN YEMEN.
IT TAKES TWO TO TANGO.
I WANT TO SEE IRAN PULLOUT OF
YEMEN AND I THINK THEY WILL.
THIS IS A QUESTION, THEY
LAUNCHED MORE THAN 200 MISSILES
INTO SAUDI ARABIA.
HOW WOULD YOU PROPOSE TO DEAL
WITH THAT?
>> THE ISSUE IS NOT ONLY GETTING
U.S. OUT OF THE WAR LED BY
SAUDI ARABIA.
WE HAVE TO DO EVERYTHING IN OUR
POWER AND WE HAVE THE POWER TO
BRING THE SAUDIS AND THE WITH
THESE TOGETHER TO END THE
INCREDIBLE DESTRUCTION WHICH IS
TAKING PLACE.
THERE IS NO DOUBT ABOUT IT.
THEY ARE PLAYING A VERY BAD ROLE
IN YEMEN AS WELL.
I THINK MOST EXPERTS WILL TELL
YOU THAT THE BULK OF THE
DESTRUCTION HAS BEEN CAUSED BY
THE SAUDIS.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, WE HAVE GOT
TO END THAT WAR, NOT
PERPETUATED.
WE HAVE GOT TO WORK WITH THE
REST OF THE WORLD AND PROVIDE
HUMANITARIAN AID TO THE CHILDREN
OF THE COUNTRY WHO ARE NOW
STARVING TO DEATH.
>> Bret: SENATOR SANDERS, HERE
IS A SECRETARY OF STATE TODAY ON
THE MURDER OF JAMAL KHASOGGI.
>> THE SAUDIS HAVE ALREADY PAID
THE PRICE.
THE FOLKS WHO ACTUALLY COMMITTED
THE MURDER, WE HELD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT.
NO ONE UNDERESTIMATES HOW
HORRIBLE THIS MURDER WAS.
REMEMBER, IRAN IS RUNNING
RAMPANT THROUGHOUT THE
MIDDLE EAST.
THE DEATH OF ANYONE IS AWFUL.
THE DEATH OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE IN EUROPE OR
THE MIDDLE EAST FOR THE
UNITED STATES THAT THERE'S AN
AWFUL LOT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS COMMITTED TO
PROTECTING AMERICA.
>> Bret: THE QUESTION IS, IF
THIS RELATIONSHIP FALTERS, DO
YOU RISK CHANGING THE NATIONAL
SECURITY OUTLOOK FOR THE
MIDDLE EAST FROM THE U.S.
NATIONAL SECURITY POINT OF VIEW?
>> NO.
ABOVE AND BEYOND THE
HUMANITARIAN DISASTER IN YEMEN
RIGHT NOW, LET ME BE VERY CLEAR.
WE HAVE BEEN IN AFGHANISTAN FOR
17 YEARS NOW.
I DO NOT WANT TO SEE THE
UNITED STATES GET SUCKED INTO A
NEVER ENDING WAR, COSTING US OUR
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
MILITARY AND TRILLIONS MORE
DOLLARS.
TO GET SUCKED INTO A
MIDDLE EASTERN WAR BETWEEN
SAUDI ARABIA AND THE OTHER HAND,
IRAN.
WHAT WE NEED TO DO IS USE
SOMETHING TO BRING THESE PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND SAY, WE
ARE NOT
SPENDING TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS
MORE.
WE WILL HELP BRING PEACE TO THAT
ENTIRE REGION.
>> Bret: I WANT TO TALK ABOUT
TWO MORE TOPICS.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS THAT THERE IS
A SHUT DOWN, HE IS FIGHTING FOR
BORDER SECURITY AND HE WILL TAKE
THAT BECAUSE HE WANTS $5 BILLION
TO FUND A WALL.
DO YOU THINK THIS CAN GET DONE?
NUMBER TWO, DO YOU THINK THE
BORDER SECURITY IS IMPORTANT?
>> I THINK BORDER SECURITY IS
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT, I THINK
BUILDING A WALL IS A VERY COSTLY
AND INEFFICIENT WAY TO DO THAT.
I'M NOT ALONE.
MANY EXPERTS THINK GIVEN THE
TECHNOLOGY WE HAVE, WE CAN
PROTECT OUR BORDER WITHOUT
BUILDING THE WALL AND SPENDING
$5 BILLION.
FURTHERMORE, I'M NOT QUITE SURE.
I'M NOT QUITE SURE THAT HE HAS
THE VOTES IN THE HOUSE TO DO
THAT.
>> Bret: AND 2013 YOU VOTED
FOR COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION.
THAT INCLUDED $18 BILLION FOR A
WALL AND BORDER SECURITY.
YOUR SANDY 5 BILLION IS A
NONSTARTER?
>> YOU 5 BILLION AS
PART AS
TENSE OF BILLIONS MORE FOR A
WHILE.
WHAT I'M SAYING RIGHT NOW,
SOMETIMES YOU VOTE FOR THINGS
THAT ARE PART OF A BROAD
PACKAGE.
IF YOU ARE ASKING ME AT A TIME
WHERE WE HAD VETERANS SLIPPING
ON THE STREET, PEOPLE ARE NOT
MAKING IT ON SOCIAL SECURITY.
THAT IS A GOOD INVESTMENT TO
BUILD A WALL?
NO, IT IS NOT A GOOD INVESTMENT.
>> Bret: I WANT TO END WITH
THIS.
YOUR PARTY, WHERE DO YOU THINK
THE ENERGY IS IN YOUR PARTY?
IS IT TOWARDS YOUR PROGRESSIVE
SIDE OF THE PARTY?
YOU THINK THE PARTY IS IN SEARC
SEARCH?
MoveOn.org HAD A POLL
YESTERDAY, THE TOP FIVE LEADING
AS A CANDIDATE POTENTIALLY AS
BETO O'ROURKE AND THEN JOE BIDEN
AND THEN YOU.
THEY OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTED YOU
THROUGHOUT 2016 SIGNIFICANTLY.
ARE YOU CONCERNED THAT THE PARTY
IS CHANGING?
>> THE PARTY JUST WON 40 SEATS
IN THE HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES
AND SEVEN GOVERNORS.
I THINK IT IS NOT JUST A PARTY.
IT IS THAT CONSERVATIVES AND
PROGRESSIVES UNDERSTAND THAT
SOMETHING IS WRONG WE HAVE A
DYSFUNCTIONAL HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM.
WE SHOULD HAVE HEALTH CARE FOR
ALL.
WE SHOULD RAISE THE MINIMUM
WAGE.
WE SHOULD REBUILD OUR CRUMBLING
INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE SHOULD END THE GREED OF THE
PHARMACEUTICAL INDUSTRY.
THEY ARE CHARGED WITH THE
HIGHEST PRICES IN THE WORLD FOR
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS.
THAT IS WITH THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WANT.
I'M GOING TO DO MY BEST TO PUSH
AN AGENDA THAT ADDRESSES THOSE
AND MANY OTHER ISSUES.
>> Bret: CAN A TEXAS
CONGRESSMAN WHO LOST THE SENATE
BID WIN YOUR PARTY'S NOMINATION?
>> I THINK IT IS A LITTLE BIT
PREMATURE.
WE HAVE --
WE HAVE SOME TIME LEFT BEFORE
THAT.
>> Bret: WHEN WE GET YOUR
DECISION?
>> WHEN HE WILL TAKE ON
WALL STREET IN THE TRUNK
COMPANIES AND TAKE ON THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES, BEFORE
DECIDE THAT I WANT TO RUN I HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS THAT
GRASSROOTS SUPPORT.
IF THERE IS, I WILL RUN AND IF
THERE ISN'T, I WON'T.
WE ARE TAKING ON BIG TIME SOME